bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 11 décembre
nouvelle édition du Journal de la
rédaction de TVfil 78 et dans
l'actualité aujourd'hui les forces de
l'ordre des ivelines expérimentent en ce
moment de nouvelles méthode de
prélèvement salivaire moins longue
qu'une prise de sang pour intensifier la
lutte contre la consommation de drogue
au volant on connaissait à l'UMP la
section des Jeunes Pop il existe aussi
depuis 2005 les jeunes actifs et ils
veulent se faire entendre en cette
période pré-électorale inviter tout à
l'heure Jérémy raou responsable
départemental
adjoint les drones un petit engin à la
mode et qui n'intéresse pas uniquement
les geeks alors qu'un appareil a été
retrouvé récemment à proximité de la
prison de boisarcy nous avons voulu
savoir comment cela fonctionnait et
surtout pour quels
usages en Irak la situation pour les
chrétiens ne arange toujours pas
persécuté par l'État islamique les
pratiquants sont obligés de fuir le pays
cet après-midi c'est une famille de H
personnes originaires d'un village près
de mousou qui a été accueilli par la
ville de saint-ciier l'école après un
long périple en passant par la frontière
turque la famille a pu rejoindre la
France et va pouvoir bénéficier d'un
logement de 80 m car ainsi que de soins
pour leur bébé de 2 mois et très malade
c'est écoutez ses réactions au micro de
William nous avons dû fuir par le nord
et dormir à même le sol dans des B sans
porte ni fenêtre c'est une amie à ma
sœur qui habite Paris qui a réussi à
faire les démarches au consulat français
c'était l'enfer et aujourd'hui c'est le
paradis à Mossou tous les chrétiens
aimeraient être à notre place en 48h la
Croix-Rouge le Secours Catholique les
restos du cœur on a tout mobilisé pour
être capable de les accueillir on va
mobiliser les services pour que d'abord
ils apprennent rapidement le français et
puis qu'il sin
dans notre pays et qu'on trouve du
travail à ceux qui peuvent travailler
invité donc aujourd'hui Jérémy raou
bonsoir vous êtes le responsable
départemental adjoint des jeunes actifs
de l'UMP vous préparez pour samedi 10h
un café politique sur les
intercommunalités en présence du
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin Michel
logier et de la présidente de l'UMP
également dans les ivelines député par
ailleurs Valérie pcrress on va en parler
dans un instant mais tout d'abord sur le
mouvement on connaissait je le disais en
titre les Jeunes Pop la branche jeune de
l'UMP à qui s'adresse ce mouvement que
vous dirigez dans dans les Yvelines des
jeunes actifs de l'UMP effectivement
quelle est la différence avec le Jeunes
Pop alors en fait la section des Jeunes
Actifs donc a été créée en 2005 par
François Guéan euh à la base c'était une
association euh
elle a été ensuite rattachée en 2010
sous l'impulsion de Jean-François Coppé
et maintenant c'est une fédération au
même titre que les Jeunes Populaires euh
alors en fait il existait un vide entre
les juniors et les médior senior on va
dire la génération des trentenaires donc
les jeunes actifs regroupent l'ensemble
des trentenaires ainsi que les jeunes
qui sont de dans la vie active
typiquement moi j'ai 26 ans donc je
rentre encore dans la catégorie Jeunes
populaire mais je suis engagé au niveau
des jeunes actiful dans l'ut catégorie
Les Jeunes Pop qu'on entend moins
d'ailleurs ces derniers temps ils n'ont
plus de président pas de subvention
depuis 3 ans c'est dire il y a une place
à prendre il y a une réorganisation en
tout cas peut-être à faire aussi
vraisemblablement de toute façon avec la
nouvelle formation politique que va
créer Nicolas Sarkozi il y aura une
refondation du mouvement jeune dans sa
globalité est-ce qu'il faut jeune pop
jeune actif sous un nouveau nom une
seule formation pour les jeunes moi
personnellement je serais plus partisan
d'une seule formation pour tous les
jeunes puisque jeune pop jeune actif on
voit bien que ça se
recoupe Nicolas Sarkozi effectivement
qui devrait se pencher rapidement sur
cette question parce que c'est important
un mouvement jeune pour une campagne et
pour peser aussi dans l'opinion on le
sait les jeunes sont très actifs quand
ils s'engagent dans ces formations
politiques il y a des noms qui circulent
aussi hein pour prendre la présidence la
tête de cette éventuelle future
formation jeune qui pourrait regrouper
aussi les jeunes actifs le point par
exemple il y a de jours évoquer une élu
d'opposition à manilamoau dont on a déjà
parlé qui est déjà venu en plateau c'est
Auror berger effectivement c'est une
bonne idée Auror berger par exemple pour
prendre la présidence elle qui a
beaucoup soutenu Nicolas Sarkozi pendant
la campagne elle s'est engagé aussi oui
il y a principalement deux noms qui
ressortent Jonas Adad de Aurore berger h
c'est deux personnes de talent qui sont
très impliqué niveau des des Jeunes
Populaires ou dans dans la vie politique
à droite donc je pense que l'un comme
l'autre serait des très bons choix les
jeunes à l'UMP aujourd'hui sont entendus
il y a pas de de voix qui se perd je je
vous pose cette question parce qu'il
existe aussi un autre groupe c'est
génération Sarkozi par exemple pas une
fédération mais qui est un mouvement de
soutien qui est né pendant la la la
campagne pour la présidence de l'UMP a
avec les Jeunes pop avec les jeunes
actifs aussi ça fait beaucoup de groupes
non c'est des groupes qui se qui se
recoupent moi par exemple je fais partie
de génération Sarkozi aussi Daniel
mzanski qui est le responsable
départemental de génération Sarkozi est
un jeune populaire il est responsable
adjoint à des Jeunes Populaires mais pas
chez des jeunes actifs donc
effectivement faire un seul mouvement ça
pourrait simplifier peut-être un petit
peu tout ça justement quel regard vous
portez sur cette idée de de renouveau à
l'UMP l'arrivée de Nicolas Sarkozi vous
l'avez dit vous l'avez soutenu pendant
la campagne donc j'imagine que vous êtes
satisfait de sa victoire mais
aujourd'hui vous en attendez quoi et
quelles avancées il faut tout changer à
l'UMP il faut changer le nom il faut
changer les statut il faut tout
revoir je pense déjà qu'on peut partir
d'un d'un socle de base qui éta déjà
existant à l'UMP les valeurs les
idées les la base mais à partir de là on
doit vraiment refonder un parti qui est
capable de de rassembler euh au centre à
droite qui est capable de d'évoquer
n'importe quel sujet
euh en gardant à l'esprit nos valeurs
sans tomber dans la démagogie sans
tomber et un mot tout de même sur les
affaires en cours on va pas revenir sur
tout l'historique sur tout ce qui s'est
passé à l'UMP on l'a déjà largement fait
ici et dans les autres médias mais ce
matin encore Guillaume Peltier ancien
vice-président de l'UMP et le dirigeant
de la société big Malon également
guillalves qui ont été placés en garde à
vue jeud dis donc à Nice les deux hommes
qui sont entendus dans le cadre de
enquête pour délit de favoritisme et
prise illégale d'intérêt à la mairie de
Menton si tout cela se terminit par une
condamnation est-ce qu'il faut les
exclure du parti est-ce qu'il va falloir
faire un petit peu le le ménage à
l'UMP euh déjà il me semble qu'il été
qu'il est sorti de garde vue sans rien
sans aucun chef d'accusation
euh deuxièmement
euh toute personne oui qui doit être qui
qui serait
condamnée personnellement je considère
qu'elle n'a pas il y a des enquêtes en
cours voilà si je POS C question il y a
beaucoup personnes qui sont impliqué il
y a beaucoup de noms qui circulent estce
parlez d'unité beaucoup à l'UMP mais
est-ce que en coulisse il y a une chasse
aux sorcières qui s'organise non
actuellement non mais typiquement on va
prendre le cas de Nicolas Sarkozi il est
cité dans beaucoup d'enquêtes mais
aujourd'hui combien de fois a-t-il été
condamné zéro les enquêtes sont pas
toutes terminées mais
effectivement pour l'instant il y a la
présempption
d'innocence moi je crois que Nicolas
Sarkozi est innocent dans ses
affaires à la justice de faire son
travail et vous quelqu'un de Nicolas
Sarkozi mais vous qui êtes engagé auprès
des des jeunes sur sur l'UMP quel est
l'état d'esprit chez chez les plus
jeunes chacun que ce soit vous ou
d'autres ont pris des positions ont
soutenu certains candidats on on soutenu
d'autres est-ce que aujourd'hui
maintenant que Nicolas Sarkozi est
revenu il y en a qui sont
écartés non Nicolas Sarkozi a a vraiment
la volonté de rassembler tout le monde
on le voit bien dans son nouvel
organigramme euh toutes les sensibilités
sont représentées et vous le ressentez
aussi vous dans vos organis locaux dans
leselines par exemple sur les jeunes
actifs sur les jeunes actifs oui l'Union
était déjà
présente on va parler de
l'ancien à partir de 2012 la guerre Copé
Fillon à la base n'existait pas
réellement les jeunes actifs comme les
jeunes populaires comme tous les autres
mouvements les militants sont toujours
restés soudés et onue à travailler
ensemble il y a il y a jamais eu de
problème là-dessus on en revient à des
préoccupations plus lo avec ce
rendez-vous sur l'intercommunalité des
jeunes actifs de l'UMP qui se déroulera
samedi 13 décembre à 10h au bar de l'UGC
50 ans neline à Montini le Bretonneux
c'est donc sous l'égite de votre branche
des Jeunes Actifs pourquoi cette
thématique de l'intercommunalité
pourquoi être parti sur cette ce thème
là pour l'échange de ce weekend disons
qu'en cette fin d'année la thématique de
l'intercommunalité est quand même très
présente surtout au niveau de
l'Île-de-France on va dire avec la loi
Matam maptam pardon euh donc avec la
position que doivent prendre les
intercommunalités avant février suite à
la proposition du préfet d'Île-de-France
notamment on va prendre le 451 ieline de
faire une
méga intercommunalité à 800000 habitants
euh qui s'étendrait jusque dans une
partie de duéendrait effectivement qui
regrouperait quatre communautés
d'agglomération donc la caskii VGP la
CCEP h
euh et Europe et voà voilà et le PL de
sa clé je sais plus si je c'est très
très large cette cette intercommunalité
et cette thématique là enfin en fait
vous vous interdisez aucun thème vous
vous dites qu'il faut apporter de la
réflexion qu'est-ce que vous comptez
apporter avec les les jeunes actifs à la
réflexion qui est déjà menée par par vos
aînés par les SEOR qu'est-ce que vous
allez apporter de plus déjà de de
l'information un débat je pense que
Michel logier qui de mieux placer à 5 an
Yveline pour parler de
l'intercommunalité et je pense qu'il il
y a vraiment quelque chose à apprendre
pour les jeunes actifs pour le public
qui sera présent samedi puisqueou à tout
le monde c'est ouvert principalement
enfin l' formation a principalement été
diffusée aux adhérents um mais tout le
monde est est le bienvenu mais je pense
que c'est vraiment de l'information qui
peut être apportée aux personnes qui
sont présentes mais aussi un retour de
terrain qui peut être offert à Michel
logier c'est en ce sens aussi
qui qui qu'il a accepté de faire ce café
politique même s'il est déjà à
l'écoute du terrain et puis c'est
toujours un honneur enfin de recevoir
des personnalités et Valérie pcress
aussi qui est annoncé et Valérie PC qui
est annoncé qui malheureusement ne
pourra pas venir finalement B alors
voilà c'est une information donelle ne
pourra pas être présente voilà parce que
samedi matin en fait il y a une réunion
de cadre faite par le président Sarkozi
au siement il faut mieux qu'elle soit
auprès de lui que de venir sur cette
réunion sur ce café politique mais il
aura quand même lieu he vous vous nous
l'avez bien autour cette thématique de
l'intercommunalité reviens à la question
que je voulais vous poser vous avez 26
ans donc vous êtes jeune vous êtes amené
à vivre dans une intercommunalité
beaucoup plus large à 800000 par exemple
si ça devait voir le jour même si les
politiques de tout bord n'en veulent pas
une intercommunalité à 800000 vous ça
vous plairait d'habiter comme ça dans
une telle intercommunalité quelque chose
de très large quelque chose qui
permettrait de faire des économies des
moyens mutualisés disons que je pense
que il faut vraiment faire ça de manière
progressive ça sert à rien d'tendre pour
étendre une intercommunalité à 800000
habitants qui s'étendrait dans les
ivelines et dans les
sones on va prendre de coignère jusque
au bout de l'esson ça ferait une heure
de trajet donc
pour une structure de proximité déjà
c'est un mauvais signal
envoyer le nombre d'élus on en serait à
plus de 250 élus communautaire digne
d'un
parlement et même en parlant des élus on
a élu des conseil communautaire en
mars pourquoi euh faire passer
des des projets sans passer par ces élus
qui sont justement euh qui ont été élus
par le peuple euh donc là ils ont donné
un
avis je pense qu'il faut respecter cet
avis et à aujourd'hui l'un après l'autre
euh les les communautés d'agglomération
émettent un avis défavorable vis-à-is ce
projet couleur politique et une
opposition à ce projet là et vous allez
en parler lors du café politique de ce
weekend vous con connaissez déjà le
thème du prochain rendez-vous que vous
allez organiser pour les jeunes actifs
alors j'ai un gros projet pour le mois
de mai h juin dans le cadre de des 60
ans de de l'armistice de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et de la construction
européenne donc c'est en coursès bien et
avant il il y aura des formations
notamment sur la prise de parle en
public sur du porte à porte il y aura
pas mal d'autres événements des des
débats organisés entre jeunes actifs
jeunes actifs Jeunes Populaires et une
préparation de la campagne de 2017 pour
Nicolas Sarkozi d'abord on va commencer
parler départemental parler régional
avec Valérie PCR qui de France tout à
fait qui sera candidate qui sera
candidate et qui sera aussi la la
gérante au niveau national pour l'UMP de
des régionales donc nous serons tous
derrière elle le jeune pop comme jeune
actif comme toutes les autres même s'il
y a une seu seule et unique structure
qui VI avoir le jour merci d'être venu
en tout cas aujourd'hui sur
plateau donc en compagnie de Michel
logier samedi l'UGC à montinil
Bretonneux pour un échange autour de
l'intercommunalité merci à vous merci un
sujet sur lequel s'affronte en ce moment
umpeps justement c'est le passe Navigo à
prix unique 70 € par mois pour tous pour
accéder au transport franilien quelle
que soit la zone pour Jean-Paul hon
l'actuel président de la Région
Île-de-France cette solution est
finançable et profitable aux usagers
faux selon son opposante et candidate on
le disait déjà en campagne pour le
prochain scrutin régional Valérie PCR
elle a signé ce matin une une tribune
publié sur le hffington post 38 autres
parlementaires dont Nathalie cossisco
Moriset ou encore François Fillon évoqu
avec elle un cadeau empoisonné et CR une
des Haus d'impôt et des investissements
en berne pour la région transport
toujours le tramoou bientôt à l'heure de
la banlieue avec le Grand Paris ce mode
de transport se développe aussi dans les
hautes scènes et les Yvelines ainsi le
T6 va relier dès ce samedi Châtillon à
véésie en 30 minutes Catherine
zulato ce samedi les ivinois pourront
enfin découvrir le tramois T6 celui qui
va relier dès à présent V à Châtillon
Châtillon où les usagers pourront
rejoindre la ligne 13 du métro parisien
une coopération entre deux départements
les Yvelines et les haute scène cette
ligne de tramois longue de 14 km compte
19 stations entre Châtillon et vilisi
dont 6 rien que sur la commune ivlinoise
cette ligne n'est pas encore totalement
terminée une partie en souterrain sera
réalisée entre vilisier et viroflet pour
une mise en service au printemps 2016 au
final cela permettra de relier
virireoflet à Châtillon en 40 minutes 30
minutes si vous parait de véisi avec des
fréquences de 4 à 7 minutes ce samedi
donc place au lancement officiel
l'inauguration se fera en fin de matinée
des animations auront lieu de 14h à 18h
à l'arrêt Wagner au terminus de la ligne
le train moi 6 aura coûté 384 millions
d'euros financé à 50 % par la Région
Île-de-France 20 % le Conseil Général
des hautes scèes 13 % le département des
ivelines et 1 % la RATP le matériel
roulant lui est estimé à 137 millions
d'euros à terme ce tramoouet devrait
être utilisé par 150000 usagers et à
noter que le sttif en charge des
transports prévoit aussi tout d'abord la
mise en place dans les 2 ans de 127 bus
hybrides afin de lutter contre la
pollution liée au véhicules diesel et
puis le renforcement de 37 lignes d'ici
la fin 2015 on peut citer la ligne rir
par exemple qui relie Versailles Gard
des chantiers à Versailles université
avec un renfort le samedi entre 6h30 et
21h40 un bus va circuler toutes les 20
minutes depuis le début de l'année 2013
le sttif qui s'occupe des transports en
commun en Île-de-France annonce avoir
améliorer près de 500 lignes de bus dans
l'ensemble de la région depuis le 1er
décembre le département des Yveline fait
partie des 10 départements français à
expérimenté les tests salivaires dans le
cadre de recherche de stupéfiants des
tests qui pourraient remplacer à terme
les prises de sang une méthode plus
rapide et surtout moins coûteuse en 2013
en France 4 % des accidents mortels de
la route étaient causé par la conduite
sous l'emprise de
stupéfiant ce mercredi soir au mur auut
ces gendarmes postés sur le bord de la
route font passer des tests salivaires
dans le cadre de recherche de produits
stupéfiants ce conducteur est négatif il
n'est pas convaincu par l'utilité de ce
test je pense que quelqu'un qui qui qui
a pas l'habitude de fumer qui fume pour
la première fois il y a du je pense
qu'il y a du du grand danger parce que
ça fait beaucoup d'effet et encore une
fois les gens qui fument depuis pas mal
d'années c'est pas un ou deux joints qui
vont le qui vont les mettre dans des
états à plus savoir ce qu'ils font voilà
et pourtant les chiffres sont là 4 % des
des accidents mortels de la route en
2013 étaent causé par la conduite sous
l'emprise de stupéfiant tous les gens ne
se rendent pas compte du fait que
consommer des produits stupéfiants
euh implique derrière des réactions
neurologiques qui ne sont pas cell
lorsque l'on est dans un état normal
c'est comme l'alcool en fait il faut
plusieurs générations pour faire
comprendre que et bien la consommation
d'alcool tout comme la consommation de
produits stupéfiants ne permet pas voir
après d'avoir des réflex euh dit normaux
lorsque l'on conduit si le test de
Benjamin avait été positif dans la
procédure actuelle il aurait dû subir
une prise de sang à l'hôpital depuis le
1er décembre cette prise de sang est
remplacée dans les ivelines par un
second test salivire dit de confirmation
et les résultats tombent en moins de 10
minutes ça évite donc d'avoir à faire
cette prise de sang qu'il faut bien sûr
confronter avec les résultats et donc
c'est un confort pour j'allais dire pour
le pour le la personne en infraction
c'est aussi j'allais dire un confort
pour les enquêteurs c'est qu'on a aussi
un délai plus rapide et plus facile
puisquehabituellement si vous voulez il
y a la prise de sang qui est faite qui
nécessite soit de transporter l'individu
à l'hôpital et ensuite de faire les
analyses plus rapidement le plus
rapidement possible les fonctionnaires
de police pourront eux-mêmes pratiquer
ce prélèvement salivaire sur le point de
contrôle ou dans un local de police ou
de gendarmerie sans avoir à passer par
la réquisition d'un médecin en milieu
hospitalier les ivelines sont des 10
départements choisis en France pour
expérimenter ce deuxème test salivaire
de confirmation si l'expérimentation
aboutit positivement les test de
confirmation pourront être étendus à
toute la France des juin 2015 en 2014
dans la zone police Yveline en a recensé
25 tués sur les routes deux personnes
ont directement été victimes de
conducteurs qui étaient sous l'emprise
de stupéfiant un garçon de 14 ans qui
circulait à vélo et un motard de 40 ans
père de
famille le débat sur la suppression des
note dans l'éducation nationale se
poursuit en ce moment et jusqu'à demain
avec une conférence sur l'évaluation des
élèves experts scientifiques équipes de
terrain présenterons leurs analyses
leurs expériences au public au jury de
cette conférence vous pouvez suivre ces
débats en direct en vous rendant sur
l'adresse internet qui s'affiche les
conclusions qui seront ensuite remises à
la ministre Najat VO Belkassem les
drones ces aéronefs miniatures
télécommandé autonomes sont maintenant
largement accessibles au grand public
certains y voient un jouet pour les
grands enfants d'autres réfléchissent à
de nombreuses applications pour le
quotidien mais cette technologie
inquiète également lorsqu'un survol de
centrale nucléaire ou encore de prison
est découvert récemment à Bois d'Arcy un
drone a ainsi été dissimulé au pied
d'une prison nous vous proposons de voir
ce soir de mieux comprendre comment cela
fonctionne et à quoi servent ces
nouveaux objets volants avec une société
ivelinoise qui les utilise régulièrement
images et commentaires de William
H cet étrange objet dans le ciel c'est
est un drone le fameux engin dont on ne
cesse de parler en cette fin d'année un
appareil muni d'hélice et télécommandé
par un opérateur équipé d'une caméra
piloté indépendamment ce dispositif
permet de réaliser des prises de vue
aériennes exceptionnelles Édouard Janier
possède une société de production à
montiny le Bretonneux il a débuté son
activité de pilote de drone voici un an
et pour lui c'est véritablement un outil
révolutionnaire on s'en sert pour de la
photo et de la vidéo puisque tous nos
drones sont équipés de de de systèmes
mixes euh on va s'en servir par exemple
pour présenter des châteaux des des des
monuments historiques pour du
tourisme pour présenter une région il y
a rien de mieux que de que de prendre un
petit peu d'altitude on va s'en servir
aussi pour de la communication on va
pouvoir aussi apporter à l'industrie des
réponses techniques sur des problèmes
qu' peuvent avoir sur des diagnostics à
faire par exemple l'état d'un pont d'une
pile de pont l'état d'une
éolienne équipé d'un GPS qui lui permet
de faire du sur placeace cet engin a une
portée théorique de 4 km avec cet
appareil tous les mouvements deviennent
possibles là c'est le GPS qui prend la
main donc on voit il bouge quasiment pas
en fait S se resserre en permanence sur
son point de départ donc il sait
exactement où il est ensuite je vais
avoir la manette des
gaz la rotation sur lui-même donc là on
le voit il tourne dans un sens ou dans
l'autre et ensuite ici je vais faire
gauche droite et en arrière en
avant
donc en fait on va piloter sur H
axes le prix moyen d'une journée de
tournage s'élève à 2000 € un tarif
beaucoup plus accessible qu'une prise de
vue avec un hélicoptère seulement voilà
le problème c'est l'autonomie pour voler
le drone a besoin de batterie qui ne
permettent pas de réaliser des vols de
longue durée en théorie sur le papier il
a 8 à 9 minutes dans la pratique on fait
jamais voler au-delà de 6 minutes ça
nous garantit une une petite marge
d'erreur une petite marge de sécurité
sur pour le retour puisque si jamais on
a une panne de batterie ça peut avoir
des conséquences importantes la première
des conséquences c'est la chute
l'utilisation des drones est donc très
réglementé c'est ici à la DGAC que les
conditions d'utilisation sont
déterminées la réglementation en fait
elle distingue deux catégories
d'utilisateur on a le grand public et
les
professionnels lorsque vous êtes grand
public on se réfère aux règles de
l'aéromodelllisme et quand vous êtes un
professionnel vous rentrez dans le cadre
activité d particulière où vous avez
quatre scénarios d'activité qui sont
définis en fonction du type de drone que
vous utilisez dans les deux cas les
conditions d'insertion dans l'espace
aérien elles sont libres en dessous de
150 m mais à trois conditions la toute
première c'est en dehors des
agglomérations des rassemblements de
personnes et d'animaux deuxièmement
c'est en dehors des zones proches des
aérro port et enfin en dehors des
espaces aériens qui sont réglementés sur
les cartes aéronautiques comme les
espaces aériens militaire ou les zones
de centrale nucléaire par exemple pour
exercer comme professionnel il faut se
faire homologuer comme pilote par la
DGAC pour le grand public l'utilisation
des images doit rester dans un cadre
privé aujourd'hui on peut acheter un
drone pour quelques centaines d'euros il
devrait donc obscurcir le ciel dans les
prochains
mois coup de pouce pour l'emploi
l'opération ce jeudi à Skywest à 50 ans
neline organisé par l'association
rencontre pour l'égalité d'accès à
l'emploi en partenariat avec la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin à l'occasion pour les
demandeurs d'emploi de rencontrer
directement les recruteurs c'est ce
qu'on constaté Catherine zulat et
William H Sabine Lacroix recherche un
emploi dans la vente depuis maintenant 2
mois et demi elle passe un premier
entretien pour intégrer une enseinene de
bricolage à Bois d'Arcy une dizaine de
minutes pour convaincre c'est plus
facile de venir à des réunions comme ça
que que d'aller dans dans une entreprise
parce que bon
c'est c'est plus convivial en fait on
voit d'autres personnes on sent moins
moins seul son entretien semble s'être
bien passé elle devrait être rappelée en
début d'année prochaine ici pour cette
enseigne ce sont trois postes
conseillers de vente deux postes
d'employé logistique et deux postes
d'utes client qui sont proposés la
rencontre directe entre employeur et
demandeur d'emploi un vrai plus là le
contact il est direct et c'est bien plus
intéressant pour nous on veut savoir
quelles sont leurs motivations et et
c'est pareil c'est un échange il faut
qu'il sachent enfin ce qu'on attend nous
deux et quelle va être leur mission
Didier lui recherche un travail depuis
plus de 2 ans c'est la première fois
qu'il vient à un forum de ce type
décrocher un entretien une vraie
satisfaction pour lui onie des CV des
les de motivation ça répond pas des
mails ça répond pas on se déplace on
nous fait attendre une demi-heure et
puis à la fin on nous dit bah non j'ai
pas le temps aujourd'hui revener
repasser bah c'est plus rapide là on
rencontre directement les les RH qui
donnent directement s'ils sont
intéressés ou s'ils sont pas intéressés
c'est plus facile que de faire du porte
à porte de tenir un
rendez-vous là c'est là ils viennent
nous voir nous donc on sait qu'ils sont
là pour ça enseignes de bricolage grande
distribution assurance bâtiment société
d'intérim ou encore fonction publique
une quinzaine d'entreprise a répondu
présent avec à la clé des emplois fixes
à proposer les candidats avaient tous
suivi des ateliers de préparation aux
entretiens car c'est souvent ce qui
pêche nous intervenons en amont ce qu'on
voit dans les ateliers de préparation
ils sont en difficulté mais une
difficulté naturelle quoi c'est pas de
de pouvoir se présenter de manière
naturelle en mettant en évidence leurs
atouts l'association rencontre pour
l'égalité d'accès à l'emploi organise 4
à 5 forums de ce type par an toutes les
entreprises présentes ce jeudi seront
rappelé dans une quinzaine de jours pour
dresser un bilan en moyenne 12 % des
candidats décrochent un emploi à l'issue
de ces
journées tout de suite sur TVfil nouveau
numéro de filch hebdomadaire dédié à
l'actualité économique des Evelin je
vous retrouve demain 18h pour un nouveau
journal très bonne soirée